okay before the break I talked to you
about the
um Conspiracy Theory with new life
essentially which it's not any it's not
it's gone from I guess I would say
some people have really bad side effects
to the vaccine
um do we know for sure that the vaccine
hasn't killed anyone they've now gone to
the vaccines for covid have killed
thousands of people
tens of thousands of people or even
hundreds of thousands of people that's
the new conspiracy now Tucker Carlson
Fox News propagandist is a guy who's
been I wouldn't even really call it
playing Coy the only aspect of it that's
koi is that Tucker is almost certainly
vaccinated
and works at Fox News which has stricter
vaccination guidelines than Joe Biden
proposed two weeks ago to the United
States remember Joe Biden's
um plan uh his directive is if you've
got more than 100 employees everybody
either has to be vaccinated
or has to test weekly okay Fox's policy
is you've got to be vaccinated and
submit your vaccination information or
you've got to test daily and you've got
to wear masks at Fox News facilities so
while on air Tucker and others are
attacking the Biden plan on vaccination
requirements Fox they work for fox which
has a stricter plan so okay Tucker he's
almost certainly uh been vaccinated he
was probably first in line as soon as he
could get it maybe even got it early all
right so Tucker has gone now from
repeating
I I hate I don't even know that I want
to use the word milder but repeating
somewhat milder conspiracies about
vaccines to now repeating the debunked
claim that thousands might be dying from
vaccinations a Media Matters has the
coverage
and says during the September 20
broadcast of Tucker tonight Tucker
railed against the vaccine requirement
for active duty service members lying
that thousands could have died that
thousands have died from the vaccine in
a segment that included claims that the
vaccination requirements are applied to
weed out and expel quote sincere
Christians in the ranks the free
thinkers the men with high testosterone
levels and anyone else who does not love
Joe Biden and accusations that the U.S
military runs PR for Satanism Carlson
claimed that a presentation given to
members of the army quote falsely claims
that only three people have died from
the vaccine Carlson then told viewers
that reports collected by the Biden
Administration itself indicate the
number is actually in the thousands I'm
going to explain that in a moment let's
listen very dangerous propaganda white
supremacy in the military is a crisis
said the most unscrupulous people in
Washington but that's not what it was
about what you just saw on tape was in
fact a power grabbed the message no one
who does not support our political party
is allowed to bear arms that's what
they're saying very clearly and because
it's the Democratic party doing the
talking here there was also needless to
say vicious racial angle too because
there always is Right watch Congressman
Steve Cohen of Tennessee explain
the guard is 90 some odd percent I
believe mail
um only about 20 of white males voted
for Biden you've got to figure that in
the guard which is predominantly more
conservative and I see that on my social
media and we know it they're probably
not more than 25 percent of the people
that are there protecting us who voted
for Biden the other 75 are in the class
that would be uh the large class of
folks who might want to uh do something
so if you're white you're dangerous says
a sitting member of Congress that clip
was from January of course that was the
same month that Lloyd Austin announced
he was cracking down on this extremism
that a few months later January was the
same month as something else too I just
don't remember what what else happened
in January later a reading from the same
song sheet Mark milley told the US
Congress he was working to root out
white rage in the military
okay
and yet after all of this because we're
keeping score as of today we're not
aware of a single white supremacist an
active duty who has been discovered by
the Pentagon and fired not one
so that threat didn't exist
interestingly would we even know if
that's the case I mean our our discharge
proceedings typically made public it's
not clear it's a question at minimum at
all it was fake that was all a lie
several National Guard troops were
relieved of Duty around the inauguration
though known as ever explained why they
were fired then a senior commander in
the space force Lieutenant Colonel
Matthew lohmeyer lost his job and we
know why his crime was criticizing
Marxism that's a firing offense now
then in August Lloyd Austin came up with
a new political purity test this one was
specifically designed to separate the
obedient from the free can't have any of
the latter category Austin said he
planned to fire anyone in the entire
armed services who would not submit to
the covid-19 vaccination shot so Tucker
now building to the case that there
should be no mandatory vaccination in
the military and then going on to say
some really really wacky things here
let's continue
that would get the Democratic party
nothing
the point of mandatory vaccination is to
identify the sincere Christians in the
ranks the free thinkers the men with
high testosterone levels and anyone else
who does not love Joe Biden and make
them leave immediately it's a takeover
of the US military here's how they're
doing it this show has just obtained a
PowerPoint that the Army is using to
justify mandatory vaccines to the Troops
this is an actual slide from it on your
screen you will notice there the
sympathetic portrayal of satanism
how many children were sacrificed to
Satan because the vaccine the slide
reads apparently sarcastically then the
presentation proceeds to list the
so-called tenets of Satanism which are
taken straight from the Temple of
Satanism website
so here you have the United States Army
doing PR for satanism
the rest of the presentation is less
shocking than that but it's utterly
shoddy and dishonest for example it
falsely claims that only three people
have died from taking the covet vaccine
reports collected by the Biden
Administration itself indicate that
number is actually in the thousands okay
so that is not true in the in even
remotely the sense that Tucker Carlson
is saying it the false reporting on the
vares system which anybody can submit is
then called Biden Administration data
that's being collected the website just
exists it was there under Trump and it
was there it continues to be there under
Joe Biden and then the false or at least
unchecked reporting of side effects and
deaths to theirs is used to say stuff
like what Tucker just said now I'm not
going to pull it I don't want to
encourage anyone to submit a false
report but you can go and look at the
very system and start the process of
submitting a report don't do it I did it
uh up until the point at which I would
have submitted it and I started typing
in David packman you know sir David
Pacman died from the vaccine treated by
this doctor you know whatever you can
just admit it anybody can submit the
information and it's being taken as
quote proof by the anti-vax to say that
all of these people are dying they take
it as gospel evidence because it's a
government website but they're ignoring
the fact that it's not verified
um anybody can show up and Report
anything and then it's part of the
reporting it doesn't mean that these are
verified vetted or confirmed instances
of vaccine issues problems or whatever
the case may be there's no validation
required there now I think it's worth
mentioning
even if it were true that thousands died
from the vaccine now I like I hesitate
to even do this because it's such a can
of worms but if it's true that let's
call it three thousand imagine three
thousand people died from the vaccine
not true but just imagine
you're still way more likely to die of
covet as a healthy person than of the
vaccine
I'm not saying it would be okay if
thousands of people died from the
vaccine but if thousands of people died
from the vaccine out of the 182 million
fully vaccinated people that would mean
you have a
0.0016 chance of dying from the vaccine
that's 500 times smaller than your
chance of dying from the virus if it
were true we would have to really think
about that but it's not true importantly
it's not true so it's Tucker again being
extremely irresponsible about vaccines
um and then also recently just just to
kind of just show you the full circle on
how irresponsible he's being he also
said Brazilian president jair bolsonaro
doesn't need to be vaccinated because he
had covid this is not true but this is
Tucker claiming it okay put them in
place not some restaurant is just
following his orders
so it allows you just issued a warning
to Brazil's president Joe bolsonaro he
told boss bolstero not to come to the
U.N General Assembly because he's not
vaccinated yeah
we need to send a message to all the
world leaders including most notably
bolsonaro from Brazil that if you intend
to come here you need to be vaccinated
if you don't want to be vaccinated don't
bother coming because everyone should be
safe together
really because Boston are already
recovered from covid so he doesn't need
the vaccine no one who's recovered from
covid needs the vaccine they have
greater immunity to people who get the
vaccine this is insane that is not true
that is a lie what's insane is that
Tucker is repeating these things we now
have multiple studies which show
you are more likely to be reinfected if
you've had covid and don't get the
vaccine then if you do get the vaccine
okay it is not true what Tucker is
saying what is apparently true is that
if you're vaccinated and recovered from
covid you have stronger immunity than if
you were merely vaccinated alone it's
not a reason to go out and try to get
covet but there are studies which say
recovery plus vaccination is better than
vaccination alone a lot of caveats
depends on timing did you recover from
one of the earlier strains or did you
recover from a later there's all these
different caveats but what Tucker is
saying is absolutely wrong and this gets
us to the next story which is that of
the Brazilian unvaccinated president one
of our sponsors is sheath underwear it
is the hottest part of the year right
now if you're a guy who wears
traditional underwear you know about the
sticking and the rubbing and the chafing
not something you have to worry about
with sheath underwear which is designed
with multiple ergonomic compartments in
the front which prevent skin on skin
contact keeping everything separate dry
cool and comfortable sheath actually
just re-released to limited edition
Styles the Flower of Life featuring a
stylish enamoring flower pattern and
bold the geometric waistband the other
limited edition style is the mesh
airflow specially designed to be
lightweight and promote extra coolness
and breathability sheath underwear was
designed by an Iraq war veteran who was
looking for a way to keep himself dry
and comfortable in the hot desert and
the underwear he developed ended up
being perfect for just about any context
in everyday use sheath underwear is
giving my viewers 20 off when you go to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
promo code Pacman